during rush hour in London social
distancing was impossible despite calls
for people to travel only when
absolutely essential a reduced service
meant thousands including key workers
were forced together on packed trains in
Brighton the picture was very different
the seafront virtually deserted the pier
closed and people using the promenade
largely adhering to the advice to stay
away from each other when were actually
out in Brighton itself like walking on
the sea front we do notice that people
are keeping distance obviously with you
know we've got it we give it to each
other anyway
we've run 18 miles and there's been no
groups of people at all and all runners
dog walkers have been step separate and
yeah hopefully everyone's take it
seriously now people here in Brighton on
the beats at least do seem to be
listening to the advice on non-essential
contact but the local authority wants to
go even further they want a complete
lockdown of the city we do need the
Prime Minister to go even further and be
much tougher and much clearer in the
messaging he needs to realise that
coastal cities and towns like Brighton
and Hove are at risk of people flooding
into us as soon as the weather gets nice
and warm and sunny and we've already
seen that last weekend you've had people
coming here on motorbikes people having
picnics on the beach and in the park
it's irresponsible and it's putting our
citizens at risk over the weekend there
were scenes of busy beaches with crowds
flouting the government's guidance
visitors flopped to national parks and
city parks the National Trust closed all
its sites and these scenes suggest the
public are now staying away as long as
there's any risk to two people we can't
open our places but we will review this
day by day week by week month by month
and it is our full intention to open
everything as soon as we can safely do
so we will the what Britain will need
the National Trust's
others when this is over there will be a
huge expression and need for the outdoor
spaces for our mountains our streams our
Hills our beaches and we want to be
there you know staffed up ready for that
for that for that need until then we're
putting our safety first and we're
following government guidance and as we
grapple with being told to stay apart
this couple are celebrating spending the
rest of their life close together
Lucy Casa Sky News